uh thanks for coming along on uh
Father's Day Happy Father's Day to the
dads amongst youth uh you know I can't
say very much just now what I will say
is reiterate the statement I issued last
Sunday I am certain that I have done
nothing wrong and tend to be back in
Parliament in the early part of the week
I'll make myself available for questions
then obviously within the constraints
that I'm referring to right now for now
I intend to go home catch up with some
family I know I'm a public figure I
accept what comes with that but I'm also
a human being that's entitled to a bit
of privacy and my neighbors are also
entitled to a better person cry as well
so thank you very much have you
considered stepping back from the SMP
I've done nothing wrong and that is the
only thing um I'm going to test out
today have there been conditions placed
on your arrest uh no and I'm not going
to get into any then other than that
would Nicholas sturgeon have suspended
Nicholas sturgeon I've done nothing
wrong it's for others to comment as they
see fit but that's my position and I'm
entitled to take it I'm going to go in
tomorrow so thank you
foreign